what is worse feeling jealous or crazy
oh my god when you put those two words
together you get jay-z should I be
getting chills about that oh my name is
Grace al peg welcome to this video
you've made a good choice already please
don't leave I mean I'm secure it is the
end of April which means it's perfect
time to do an April favorites these are
things that I have enjoyed this month
aka most of these things I bought like
two days ago and like on a decent level
first yeah yeah say yeah yeah say yeah
yeah say yeah this is the healthy
deodorant is actually literally the name
of it is it really recently I heard that
aluminum in deodorant is not good for
you
no follow up questions please and I
happen to see this on Amazon
it is a deodorant that does not have
aluminum it says no aluminum on the
front right there and it also has no
parabens that's fine I don't need a pair
of bins I'll take one bins stay I've
been using this over the course of this
month and I think my body is healthier
this is from lab vanilla laboratories
and the scent is fresh vanilla lemon and
it smells really really good which is I
think mostly why this is a favorite I
put it in my armpits and then I also put
it here like perfume because I'm not
better than that just wait you're gonna
see Kylie Jenner doing that in like a
week
next yeah yeah say yeah yeah say yeah
yeah say this is l'oreal paris is
sublime bronze summer express wash off
body makeup lotion more words please
wasn't Duane Reade a couple days ago in
New York and I bought this thinking it
was similar to that Neutrogena body
lotion that tans you subtly over time
and I put this on the way I put that
other lotion on and wow this is way more
pigmented than that this is actually
like foundation for your skin but then
the more I like smash
it into my skin I think the better it
looked and the more natural it looked
it's still there from a couple days ago
lasted and it didn't get on my clothing
which is a huge huge deal because I wore
a series of white shirts in New York
because I loved creating unnecessary
challenges for myself I guess this says
it washes off and I wouldn't know that
because I have yet to shower since being
think York so it's still on my skin but
I'm assuming it probably does Gandhi
always says those who assume and then he
forgot that he was doing about silence
so no really finish the quote
unfortunately I'll just show you so you
can kind of see like how thick this is
whoa yeah it's definitely makeup for
your body watch this this is gonna look
real aggressive and it's not gonna be a
good seller of this product but trust me
it will blend in better than what this
is gonna do Wow look at that look how
good it was why did I actually do that
figure this out just is where you learn
to problem-solve look this one doesn't
have as much out this is this one but
that looks fairly natural the one thing
I did do in New York after I put it on
and I realized that I possibly made a
huge mistake is I took a makeup wipe and
just lightly went over it to kind of
make it more subtle and blend it in and
it really helped not the worst thing in
the whole damn world next Matt can say
okay I'll say okay I'll say this I also
bought in New York a couple days ago
because I had some meetings and I
realized I was gross head to toe and
should cover everything in something
this is Sally Hansen's insta-dry nail
color in I rush look I rush luck so I'll
pretend that didn't happen it's green
and I have it on my nails right now look
how beautiful I love Sally Hansen's
insta-dry I think I've talked about it
in other favorite videos before I put
one coat on and with in under five
minutes
it was totally dry
next yeah you say okay I found this this
became a favorite about ten minutes ago
when I put it on my eyes before shooting
this video this might have been in a
video before I learned to talk like this
this is to face better than false lashes
extreme and it's a two-step mascara
process this big ol guy's step one and
three it's just you know mascara but
then step two this its these fibers can
you see that whoa it's a spy burr brush
thing oh you put a coat of mascara on
your eyes and then you put some fibers
in here which feel like you're just
shoving lint into your eyelashes and
then you put another coat over top and
the fibers just sort of meld into your
lashes and create false eyelash or
eyelash extension type of look look at
look at look at that act these these
also might have been in a video before
one of my favorite things is my short
term these are key sunglasses this is an
Australian brand of sunglasses I got one
Anna memory now we're doing our no
filter tour in Australia Oh whose face
just got super tiny I like them because
they make me feel like a toddler that
has parents that put glasses on them to
try and make like a funny youtube video
neck they can't say okay I'll say I'll
say oh these are sandals that I got at
Zara they look like this they have
zippers in the back which is my number
one priority for summer sandals I love
that so much I refuse to buy those
sandals with the tiny little latches
that you have to latch around your ankle
and it takes forever and you can't get
it and when you're bent over just hoping
that like your shirt and your pants
continue to work together to keep
strangers from seeing your butt crack
you know that like strangers are
probably seeing your butt crack you're
like it's okay I'll never see them again
well maybe I will see them again also I
hope I didn't like wipe weird so these
are cute and I like them next yeah yeah
say yeah yeah say yeah I'll say this is
a skirt that I bought at H&M in
city also a couple days ago I bought it
because I didn't have clothes to wear
for a bunch of meetings and interviews
that I was doing I was so pleasantly
surprised to find this at H&M it's all
this like rhinestone knee stuff on it
and I think this skirt was like 40 bucks
maybe which is insane for something like
this
and it's really nice quality so I am
very happy with it and I wore it and the
beads didn't fall off of it which is
really great um and yeah next yeah yeah
say yeah say yeah yeah yeah this is a
sweater I got at Topshop in New York oh
sure I like it very much I love high
neck loathing and I love the colors on
this and I got so many compliments about
this it's crazy if any of you saw any of
the live interviews that I did via like
Facebook livestream yesterday in New
York then you saw this sweater on me I
wore it all day yesterday and a lot of
people seem to like it I feel like it's
wearing the opening credits of Saved by
the Bell on your person yeah yeah can't
see I can't see in case that you can't
see it I know I know I'm so so behind
but one of my absolute favorites is I'm
finally watching all of Arrested
Development and it is so good and I'm
sure you all know this already so I'm
sorry to be wasting your time but just
PS a friendly reminder Arrested
Development is amazing thinking of the
amazing another favorite lemonade haha I
started watching lemonade on Sunday in
my hotel room in New York on my phone
and I got so excited about it that I had
to go down to the gym and walk on a
treadmill to watch it because I couldn't
sit still while I was watching it I like
it very very much I have to move on
because I'm gonna who knows I don't even
know that's how lemonade makes me feel
next you see I can't see if you didn't
know you can't see it next is I will
probably be bringing this up in almost
every favorites video from here on out
it is the app dish dish is the food at
that Hannah memory Ingrid and I are
involved in it's basically Instagram
meets Yelp where you can post photos of
food and review the food
and the place that you got it from look
at all the foods look at all the tubes
if you love photos of food and hate
being shamed for posting food photos on
Instagram please download dish dys H I'm
a huge fan of it and I hope you are too
there's more and more people using it
and Hanna Mae Murray Ingrid and I are
checking in every day and following you
guys and liking your photos and checking
it all out so I think you should also
check it out please and thank you no
follow-up questions that's it that's it
for April favorites I hope that you
enjoyed this video if you did give it a
thumbs up and do not forget to subscribe
to this YouTube channel that would be a
really cool thing for you to do look
there's a helpful button right there I'm
making this so easy for you if not for
me do it for Beyonce see goose' grease
eye I see you I don't know I put one
coat on and within under five minutes
it was totally dry which is great for me
because I'm a child
how do people let me stay in hotel rooms
alone mmm same way I don't know how to
strive so fast no follow-up questions